il est le premier dirigeant étranger à
être reçu à l'elysée est depuis la
réélection des manuels macron arènes
drame audi espère renforcer les liens
entre l'inde et la france même si la
guerre en ukraine est un sujet épineux
entre les deux pays new delhi n'a jamais
condamné l'invasion russe en ukraine
l'inde dépend beaucoup de la russie en
termes de livraisons d'armes mais sur ce
point la france entretient depuis
quelques années des relations de plus en
plus étroite avec l'inde les
exportations de matériel militaire en
inde ont d'ailleurs été multiplié par
dix entre 2017 et 2021 signe de ce
rapprochement l'achat de 36 avions
rafale en 2016 pour un montant de près
de 8 milliards d'euros dont les premiers
ont été livrés en 2020
nous terminons aujourd'hui la cérémonie
qui marque officiellement la livraison
du premier rafale à lundi dia est mort
cet événement marque une étape
structurante dans le partenariat
stratégique entre nos deux pays je
remonte à 1998
autre livraison par la france des avions
de combat mirage ou des sous marins
scorpène mais c'est au moment de la
crise des sous marins australiens que
les deux pays ont tenté de montrer leur
union lorsque canberra a rompu son
contrat avec paris pour se tourner vers
les etats-unis et le royaume-uni la
france et l'inde avait affirmé renforcer
leurs liens dans la zone indo pacifique
emmanuel macron hainard and g audi
espère chacun y être influent avec un
objectif commun
résistera l'expansionnisme chinois